The player 1 in Squid Game was indeed the winner in real life.
South Korean actor O Yeong-su won Best TV Supporting Actor at this year's Golden Globe Awards...
...for his role in Squid Game.
The 77-year-old actor, O Yeong-su, played the elderly participant, Oh Il-nam.
He beat Billy Crudup and Mark Duplass of "The Morning Show,"...
...Kieran Culkin of "Succession" and Brett Goldstein of "Ted Lasso"...
...to clinch the award in the Best TV Supporting Actor category.
After 58 years of his acting career,...
...O now became the first South Korean actor ever...
...to secure an acting trophy at the Globes.
Since its official release in September last year,...
...Squid Game swept Netflix's top popular charts across the world...
...reaching the number one spots in more than 90 countries.
It also became the most watched Netflix content of all time...
...with a total of 1.65 billion hours of streaming...
...in the first four weeks of release.
With these record-breaking achievements....
...Squid Game became the first South Korean drama to be awarded at the Gotham Awards...
...and nominated in the Best TV Drama Series at the Golden Globe Awards.